[Music]
the end is near credit run from it dusty
still alive
the best thing about mob every single
movie has set the chessboard up for this
really tense standoff each character has
an environment that they fit in and it's
nice to move some of those pieces around
after lucky that I got to be the one to
go infiltrate Wakanda cap opens a door
into childhood heart it opens a place
where he can trust outsiders should we
bow yeah he's a kid what are you doing
we we don't do that we're seeing what
Wakanda can bring to the Avengers they
need support and help to deal with a
very major global threat and of course
what Conda and wakandans are the best to
partner with you'll buy and walk on down
now this is the place where we should
rally and try to win this is a pretty
amazing universe it's just huge as the
Guardians Miss Thor and his people you
know that is people for more condos is
everybody's just gathering together to
defeat an enemy pretty awesome so good
on what Conda put on us Derek don't
fight for one less fight for all of them
the entire time I knew him he only ever
had one call
to wipe out half the universe if he gets
all the Infinity stones she can do it
with the snap of his fingers just like
that tell me his name again
danos
[Music]
we got one advantage
he's coming to us
we have a dance once so that's what we
use
[Music]
let's talk about this plan dears I think
it's good except it sucks so let me do
the plan and that way it might be really
good
Wow
the end is near
and um
[Music]
half of humanity will still exist
perfectly balanced
this whole thing should be
I hope they remember you
[Music]
I'm Peter by the way dr. strange Oh
using your made-up names then I am
spider-man
[Music]